assets I don't care even if I die you
know
I want to go there is the last chance I
have
we were there for a few hours maybe six
seven hours and then the British Coast
Guard rescued us
that time I understood how small our
boat was
I am from Iran it's taken three years
for Nema to build the life in the UK it
was the first week we came to London I
met amazing people from different
cultures different backgrounds different
life story and it was great to learn
about each cultures he lost friends who
drowned crossing the channel before him
she didn't want a lot from this world
and she wanted to have a better life
maybe in the end maybe she thought she
will have the future
but never thought twice about risking
his own life
there is no safe routes for Middle East
people
there are some rules but it doesn't
include us otherwise we are not stupid
to pay loads of money and risk Our Lives
to come here we take these hard journey
because we don't have any other options
and what a lot of people ask is why not
France I couldn't speak French and I
knew it's going to take ages for me
people were so close against refugees
and I wanted to integrate I wanted to
you know do something with my life
I can't say how many people from here
came to the UK it's estimated just nine
people came here on safe routes from
Iran in the first nine months of last
year when I see it I feel close to my
father Nema spent nearly half a decade
in refugee camps in Greece and France he
tried to cross a channel four times now
he's here he's training to be an NHS
nurse
but Small Boat Crossings bring up strong
feelings on both sides as Asylum Seekers
are dispersed around the country anger
has spilled over in places like nosley
outside hotels housing migrants
problems successive ministers and new
laws haven't fixed now a new bill is
being unveiled making it illegal to
claim Asylum if you've crossed the
channel then the wave is coming
and the other way can't you turn
yourself
Sunni not his real name also came here
from Iran
do you find it upsetting personally you
know when you see people protesting
outside and you hear the language that's
used
oh yeah I saw him very upset they are a
fear of most of them sad because they
think or no the people of the old side
watch all of us with the same eye I'm
not want to be something extra on the
shoulder of these people I should work I
should have something valuable for these
people
far-right protests outside hotels like
this have unsurprisingly been widely
criticized but these places have become
flashpoints in the argument about
immigration Small Boat Crossings have
become symbolic and this issue matters a
long way from the south coast
not far away in Stoke on Trent one of
the most Lee voting places in the
country the local MPS out speaking to
constituents I understand they do have
to go somewhere but it still seem rather
a lot in one area at one time you don't
have to look far here to find a view
more needs to be done to either support
those people or ideally prevent The
Crossings that's money that could be
going into the education system and
Jonathan gullis has been one of the most
vocal conservatives on the subject of
small boats I think it is absolutely
something that's going to be detrimental
to the conservative party in this local
area it'll be conservative voters who
choose to sit at home or even protest
vote and go to reform if you were
someone
I would say I would disagree what
baroness Scotland a former labor
Minister said you should go to the first
safe country and claim a time there and
those are bordering Nations why should
France for example take more people than
us well I don't think people should be
traveling all the way through Mainland
Europe to get to France in order to
attempt coming over by a small boat I
think it's actually the Humane thing to
want to stop people being willing to
risk their lives I think that the
homosexual is replicating what is being
said in my own constituency and those
across the country which is when we have
40 plus thousand people coming here
illegally it's going to cause a major
concern for the safety for security of
our country but also undermine the very
principle of taking back control of our
laws and our borders
and his is a view that chimes with other
Tories if you expect new laws to be a
quick fix there'll be huge practical
challenges but it does send a message to
people like Nema
I was in love with British values when I
was in Iran you know you come here you
see people who think they are really
British they don't know their own values
and it's kind of sad for me
your own value says respect other
cultures then he you use this kind of
vocabulary to describe refugees who
lost everything you know nobody wants to
be a refugee
how can you do that these are the basic
human rights I left my country because I
didn't have democracy I try to distance
myself
but I can't
and at the same time I say we don't have
a right to say anything you are guest in
this country
but up and down the country outside
hotels in towns and Villages people care
about immigration
prime minister knows that and knows a
political danger that will come if he
doesn't stop the boats